hace poco más de tres meses estaba en
una situación en la que probablemente
muchos de ustedes han estado de manera
reciente era poco antes de navidad'
estábamos en uno de los peores momentos
justo de la pandemia y yo quería junto
con mi esposa y con mi bebé ir a ver a
mis abuelos
aparentemente era algo sencillo ir o no
ir
si iba tal vez era hacerme la prueba o
no hacerme la aparentemente todo era
sencillo pero me estaba costando
muchísimo trabajo no podía dormir le
daba vueltas y algo aparentemente
sencillo se me estaba complicando en lo
absoluto para mí en ese momento ese era
una decisión de vida o muerte
y yo les quiero preguntar a quien de
ustedes considera que le cuesta trabajo
tomar decisiones
varios y es curioso porque justo tomar
decisiones es de las actividades que nos
hace plenamente humanos
justo al tomar decisiones ponemos de
manifiesto las tres facultades
superiores del ser humano la
inteligencia la voluntad y la
afectividad algunos podrán decir bueno
los animales tienen inteligencia se
podría debatir algunos podrían decir los
animales tienen afectos pero lo que sí
les puedo asegurar es que solamente el
ser humano puede poner de manifiesto las
tres al mismo tiempo y al momento de
tomar decisiones
justo lo hacemos y entonces yo me
pregunto
[Música]
porque nos cuesta tanto tomar decisiones
para tratar de resolver esta pregunta es
un poco investigue y vaya distintas
cosas y les quiero compartir cuatro
razones por las que considero que nos
cuesta trabajo tomar decisiones
la primera es porque tomar decisiones es
algo que ocurre en soledad
tú puedes pedirle opinión a muchísima
gente puedes preguntar puedes
consultarlo lo pones en tus redes
sociales en instagram haces encuestas lo
que tú quieras pero al final la decisión
es tuya eres tú y la decisión y
cualquier cosa que implica que sea en
soledad no nos gusta nos cuesta trabajo
en segundo lugar tomar decisiones
implica asumir compromisos y
responsabilidades podremos dedicar
prácticamente toda una plática solo
hablar de eso y podríamos incluso
debatir si hoy en día a las nuevas
generaciones quieren asumir menos
responsabilidades o no pero lo que es un
hecho es que tomar decisiones nos
implica asumir responsabilidades y
asumir responsabilidades nos da miedo
en tercer lugar tenemos el hecho de que
nos cuesta trabajo tomar decisiones
porque cada día tenemos más opciones en
todo de hecho hay un libro que se llama
the paradox of choice
y en él el doctor barry schwartz justo
nos habla de que si bien uno podría
pensar que entre más opciones tienes más
feliz eres más libre te sientes y todo
funciona mejor no es así
al revés entre más opciones tenemos más
se nos complica todo
la verdad no es que yo sea un gran toma
no es que yo sea un gran tomador de café
pero yo recuerdo que anteriormente si tú
ibas a pedir un café te preguntaban
bueno el café lo quieres con leche o sin
leche tal vez te preguntaban lo quieres
con azúcar o sin azúcar
hoy en día pedir un café es un verdadero
tema no primero decidir qué grano de
café qué tipo de tostado qué tipo de
leche y ahora puedes pedir incluso con
leche deslactosada y con café
descafeinado y ya al final por fin
decides cuál es tu café y te ve te dicen
bueno y quiere redondear para alguna
institución y ya tú lo único que quería
será pedir un café y como eso les
aseguro que hay muchísimos ejemplos cada
uno de ustedes podrá tener algún algún
ejemplo que se le ocurra de un tema
sencillo en los que tienen muchas
opciones y eso lo vuelve más complicado
pero el cuarto motivo por el cual nos
cuesta trabajo tomar decisiones y del
que hoy les quiero venir a platicar es
porque toda decisión implica una
renuncia
y muchas veces estas renuncias son
evidentes y son relativamente sencillas
ustedes para venir aquí el día de hoy
seguramente tuvieron que renunciar a
algo tal vez renunciaron a ir a sus
clases tal vez renunciaron a ir al
gimnasio no sé cada uno habrá renunciado
algo yo para decidir ponerme el traje
azul tuve que renunciar ponerme el saco
el traje gris no había de otro pero a
veces estas renuncias son mucho más
complejas hay momentos en que tienes que
renunciar tal vez a tus valores hay
momentos en que tienes que renunciar tal
vez a tus planes a algún proyecto que tú
tenías y llega el momento en que tienes
que tomar esa acción y tienes que
renunciar a ellos y lo malo además es
que no nos gusta renunciar a nada no
queremos renunciar a nada queremos todo
lo queremos de inmediato en el momento y
es más también lo podríamos pedir con el
menor sufrimiento con la menor tristeza
con el menor costo y si tiene algún
costo lo pedimos a meses sin intereses
pero no es así toda decisión va teniendo
una consecuencia va teniendo renuncias
es más parte de no querer renunciar a
nada
hoy en día incluso existe un síndrome
seguro algunos de ustedes lo han
escuchado incluso mal más de uno seguro
se sentirá identificado con el fondo
fear of missing out y yo trataba de
pensar a la hora de haber es realmente
es miedo a perderse de que y no lograba
entenderlo no sé es como miedo a
perderse de algo que no estoy seguro que
es ese algo que tampoco estoy seguro si
puede pasar o no pero me da miedo que no
vaya a pasar algo así recuerdo una
anécdota hace como tres años un alumno
que estaba de intercambio y entonces me
contó muy contento como le estaba yendo
padrísimo todo y de repente me dice oye
ricardo además el viernes de la semana
pasada estuve una fiesta en mexico con
todos mis amigos y yo por a lo mejor por
regreso donde estaba intercambio no me
conecté y entonces yo estaba
en otra parte del mundo pero me conecte
y esta y que padre la verdad dije a tus
oral que buena onda pero es parte de lo
que nos pasa no queremos renunciar a
nada porque además nos han dicho nos han
dado el mensaje de que tomes todas las
oportunidades que puedas es más yo he
sido muchas veces el primero que les
dice y tomen todas las oportunidades que
puedan y los que te dicen nunca te des
por vencido nunca te des por vencido y
suena bien pero justo preparando esto yo
pensaba no habrá veces en que sea
importante no tomar alguna oportunidad
o tal vez hay momentos en que realmente
vale la pena darse por vencido y decir a
ver ya lo intenté realmente intenté este
proyecto lo más que podía pero en este
momento es mejor dejarlo a un lado para
poder dar un paso
en el 2018 publicaba en un artículo del
new york times' y parte del artículo lo
que decía era que habían entrevistado a
un grupo de personas que estaban en una
fila todos aquí en algún momento de
nuestra vida hemos tenido que hacer
filas y ahí estaban y entonces las
personas llevaban las personas que
estaban allí llevaban media hora
formados y en eso les avisaron oigan
pues una disculpa vamos a tener que
tardar una hora más más o menos van a
perder a van a tardar una hora en
atenderlos ustedes pueden esperar aquí o
pueden regresar a algún otro día y la
mayoría de ellos decían que preferían
permanecer y esperar a que les
atendieran
y tal vez eso no estaba mal pero lo
interesante es la justificación porque
ellos decían es que si yo me voy ahorita
siento que es como si hubiera perdido
esa media hora que ya llevo formado no
es como si estuviera perdiendo eso
y ahorita estamos hablando tal vez de
una fila pero cuántas veces no nos pasa
eso en nuestra vida que lo único que nos
hace estar en un lugar es el tiempo que
llevamos ahí
cuántas veces no te puede pasar eso tal
vez en una relación que de repente te
cuestionas piensas y lo único por lo que
sigues ahí es por el tiempo que llevas
estando ahí o nos puede pasar en un
trabajo que de repente voltea sin saber
lo único que me hace permanecer y seguir
aquí es que llevo muchísimo tiempo no y
entonces justo no nos da oportunidad de
dar un paso adiós antes de dar un paso
hacia adelante de pensar otras
posibilidades a mí me toca o me ha
tocado mucho trabajar con deportistas y
a veces lo más difícil para un
deportista es justo decidir en el
momento en que tiene que dar un paso
adelante hacer otras cosas probablemente
renunciar a su sueño de seguir siendo
profesional para intentar otras cosas
pero mientras no lo dé no puede avanzar
y por mucho tiempo nos han dicho que
nuestras decisiones son las que nos
hacen libres
pero realmente la renuncia es la que nos
hace plenamente libres
y para alcanzar esta renuncia para
alcanzar estas decisiones yo observo dos
llamar enemigos pero dos riesgos que
muchas veces tenemos al decidir uno es
tratar de alargar lo más posible la
decisión no darle vueltas y esperar y
esperar tratar de que no la tenga que
tomar yo y no nos damos cuenta que en
esos casos el no decidir ya es una
decisión y en ese momento lo que estamos
poniendo justo lo que estamos
renunciando es al tiempo al tiempo un
recurso que se agota un recurso limitado
y muchas veces por no decidir perdemos
eso pero en otras ocasiones otro de los
riesgos que tenemos al tomar decisiones
es que tomamos la decisión pero nos la
pasamos todo el tiempo
recriminan donoso pensando que hubiera
pasado sin que hubiera pasado si tomaba
otra decisión que hubiera pasado si no
iba
y un sinfín de posibilidades que se
podrían dar porque lo hubiera no existe
y entonces podemos ir pensando toda la
cantidad de posibilidades que podrían
haber sido y nunca fueron y lo difícil
es que justo eso no te permite disfrutar
el momento estás todo el tiempo pensando
en lo que pasó o en lo que no hiciste o
en posibilidades remotas que no van a
pasar porque no decidiste eso y dejas de
disfrutar el momento por eso yo les
quiero plantear una tercera alternativa
que es
asumir la decisión
y abrazar la renuncia
yo sé que pude haber tomado muchas otras
decisiones incluso puede ser que alguna
de algunas de esas decisiones haya sido
mejor alguna otra decisión pero no
importa yo estoy aquí decidido eso y
abrazo todas las posibilidades de cosas
que pudieron haber sido pero no van a
ser y para tratar de alcanzarlo para
tratar de lograrlo les quiero dar un
regalo
o sea que a todos nos gustan los regalos
y este es un regalo muy sencillo este
regalo es una frase una frase que les
puedo asegurar que todos hemos escuchado
alguna vez de hecho yo ya lo dije en
esta conferencia sin darme cuenta y
alguien lo dijo hace rato también en
otra conferencia y es la frase vale la
pena
todos aquí lo hemos escuchado
seguramente a ustedes les dijeron oye
qué padre que vas a ir a tdt anáhuac
university querétaro vale muchísimo la
pena o tal vez en la universidad te han
dicho oye mete la clase con ese maestro
realmente vale mucho la pena o a lo
mejor algunas de ustedes les han dicho
oye felicidades por tu novio ese
muchacho vale la pena
pero alguna vez han pensado
cuál es la pena que implica eso al decir
vale la pena cuál es la pena al meter
clase por ejemplo con ese maestro
pues la pena probablemente es que si tú
metes clase con ese maestro no la vas a
poder meter con otros y en ese mismo
horario no vas a poder meter otra
materia pero no pasa nada porque sabes
que meter la clase con ese maestro vale
la pena cuál es la pena de tu novio
bueno si la van a américa eso sí es una
pena pero cuál es la pena cuando tienes
ese muchacho vale la pena no no es la
pena que tienes cuando lo vas a
presentar con tus papás es la pena que
implica que si tú decides estar con él
automáticamente renuncias a estar con
alguien más o eso se supondría porque
entonces cuando tú estás con ese
muchacho cuando tú estás con esa
muchacha sabes que vale la pena sabes
que no necesitas estar con nadie más
porque estar con él o estar con ella
vale la pena
yo hace tres meses que les contaban
sabía que en el fondo si yo iba a ver a
mis abuelos iba a implicar alguna pena o
tal vez tendría y tenía la pena puede
tener me que hacer una prueba de
coronavirus de tenerla que pagar de
tener que esperarme dos días a lo mejor
a que me dieran los resultados
sabía que incluso me implicaba una
renuncia la renuncia del control la
renuncia de tener plena seguridad de que
todo iba a estar bien y saber que lo
tenía que poner en manos de dios
pero en el momento en que yo los vimos
en el momento en que los vi con mi bebé
en ese momento me di cuenta de que todas
las decisiones habían valido la pena
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]